Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. The British Empire, Sir John Seeley famously opined at the end of the Victorian period, was acquired in a fit of absence of mind. It's become a very popular way of summing up the way in which the British Empire came together, but lots of historians have disputed it, and among those historians is the noted chronicler of Victorian battles, high life and depravity Sir Harry Flashman. George Macdonald Fraser's great anti-hero in Flashman and the Mountain of Light novel published in 1990 scoffs at Seeley's judgment. Presence of mind if you like
感谢您收听《历史余温》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的加更节目、享受无广告体验、抢先收听系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入会员俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。维多利亚时代末期，约翰·西利爵士曾有一句名言：大英帝国是在一种“心不在焉”的状态下获得的。这句话已成为总结大英帝国形成方式的一种非常流行的方式，但许多历史学家对此提出了质疑，其中就包括维多利亚时代战争、上流社会和堕落生活的著名记录者——哈里·弗莱什曼爵士。乔治·麦克唐纳·弗雷泽在1990年出版的小说《弗莱什曼与光明之山》中，借这位伟大的反英雄之口，嘲笑了西利的判断。如果你愿意的话，那叫“心在焉”。
he says and countless other things such as greed and Christianity, decency and villainy, policy and lunacy, deep design and blind chance, pride and trade, blunder and curiosity, passion, ignorance, chivalry and expediency, honest pursuit of right and determination to keep the bloody frogs out. Dominic, who do you side with uh seeley or um sir harry flashman oh the flat i mean you've always got i think we should all start all our podcasts with flashman i mean the good you know it's going to be a good podcast you also know that nothing anybody says will be as as good again in the in the next 45 minutes but um i'm a flashman man on this so clearly i mean the great thing about that quote we talked about flashman in the historical fiction episode. And the great thing about Flashman, the account of the 19th century
他说，还有无数其他因素，比如贪婪与基督教、体面与卑劣、政策与疯狂、深谋远虑与盲目偶然、骄傲与贸易、失误与好奇、激情、无知、骑士精神与权宜之计，以及追求正义的诚实与把那些该死的法国佬挡在门外的决心。多米尼克，你支持谁？是西利还是哈里·弗莱什曼爵士？哦，弗莱什曼，我的意思是，我觉得我们都应该以弗莱什曼作为我们所有播客的开场，因为你知道这会是一期精彩的播客。你也知道，在接下来的45分钟里，没人说的话会比这更精彩了。但嗯，在这件事上我是弗莱什曼的支持者，很明显，我们在历史小说那一期节目里谈到过弗莱什曼，那段引语最棒的地方在于，关于弗莱什曼，关于19世纪的记述，
in the British Empire, is that it's actually, there's layer upon layer of ambiguity and irony and nuance. And there absolutely is all that in that quotation, isn't there? Because so much is packed in. And I think there's so much complexity there that actually reflects the imperial experience, greed, missionary spirits, keeping the frogs out, valour, decency, villainy, corruption, all those things are there. And that's what makes this story so rich, but also so controversial, that you can actually see in it, as the Flashman quotation suggests, you can see in it whatever you like. And so that is essentially contemporary attitudes to the British Empire. I mean, it's an absolutely live issue. And I got that quote from a book that's not only a survey of that, but has become a vital contribution to the entire debate,
在大英帝国，实际上，它有着一层又一层的歧义、讽刺和细微差别。那段引语里绝对包含了所有这些，不是吗？因为它包含的内容太丰富了。我认为其中蕴含的复杂性实际上反映了帝国经历：贪婪、传教士精神、把法国佬挡在门外、英勇、体面、卑劣、腐败，所有这些都在其中。这正是这个故事如此丰富，但也如此充满争议的原因，正如弗莱什曼的引语所暗示的那样，你实际上可以在其中看到任何你想看到的东西。所以，这本质上就是当代对大英帝国的态度。我的意思是，这是一个绝对现实的问题。我从一本书中引用了那段话，那本书不仅是对这一问题的综述，而且已成为对整个辩论的重要贡献，
Satnam Sanghera's Empire Land, which came out, I think, at the beginning of this year. And we are hugely honoured to have the author with us on the podcast. And before I introduce him fully, probably, I should just mention Jeet Baines, who was the matchmaker over this. He introduced us on Twitter. I mean, we all followed each other, but he kind of suggested that Santa come on and talk about it. So thank you very much, Jeet. And above all, thank you, Santa, for coming on and talking to us. Pleasure. I'm a fan of the podcast. I'm hoping we can all get cancelled as a result of this conversation.
萨特南·桑格拉（Satnam Sanghera）的《帝国之地》（Empire Land），我想是在今年年初出版的。我们非常荣幸能邀请到作者来到我们的播客。在正式介绍他之前，我可能应该提一下吉特·贝恩斯（Jeet Baines），他是这次交流的牵线人。他在推特上介绍了我们认识。我的意思是，我们都互相关注，但他建议让桑格拉来谈谈这本书。所以非常感谢你，吉特。最重要的是，感谢桑格拉来和我们交流。不客气。我是这个播客的粉丝。我希望我们能因为这次谈话而被“取消”掉。
Well, I think Dominic's the likeliest to get cancelled. I think I've probably been cancelled already. I've been cancelled so many times I've got the scars. On the topic of Flashman, to begin with, we talked about him. We had an episode on historical fiction. And I said that I thought that I was surprised that Flashman hadn't been cancelled, to be honest. Because, you know, I mean, the voice is that of a very racist Victorian adventurer. And I wonder what your perspective on that.
嗯，我觉得多米尼克最有可能被“取消”。我想我可能已经被“取消”过了。我被“取消”过太多次了，身上都留下了伤疤。回到弗莱什曼的话题，我们之前谈到过他。我们做过一期关于历史小说的节目。老实说，我说过我很惊讶弗莱什曼竟然没有被“取消”。因为，你知道，他的声音是一个非常种族主义的维多利亚时代冒险家的声音。我想知道你对此有何看法。
I mean, do you find Flashman funny? Do you find him convincing as a historical voice? You know, I mainly think of David Cameron, because people always compare the two, don't they? And so I now cannot read Flashman without thinking David Cameron's reading it. And actually, I was reading Our Island Story yesterday, which David Cameron picked as his favourite children's book of all time. And I couldn't believe, I mean, it's one of the most famous history books of all time, isn't it? I just couldn't believe how it barely touched upon empire. And when it did, it was talking about the black hole of Calcutta, the mutiny, the Indians behaving terribly after
我的意思是，你觉得弗莱什曼有趣吗？你觉得他作为一个历史声音有说服力吗？你知道，我主要想到的是大卫·卡梅伦，因为人们总是把他们俩做比较，不是吗？所以我现在读弗莱什曼时，脑子里总会浮现出大卫·卡梅伦在读它的样子。事实上，我昨天在读《我们的岛屿故事》（Our Island Story），大卫·卡梅伦把它选为他有史以来最喜欢的儿童读物。我简直不敢相信，我的意思是，这是有史以来最著名的历史书之一，不是吗？我简直不敢相信它几乎没有触及帝国。当它提到时，谈论的是加尔各答黑洞、兵变，以及印度人在兵变后的糟糕表现。
the mutiny. If that's your view of empire, and then you become prime minister, you're going to be in trouble, man. So let's cut to the chase because when I was kind of previewing that you were coming on the podcast, and I was reading your book, and I quoted from the book, and it gave me a sense of what, obviously, you've been living through
如果你对帝国的看法是这样，然后你又当上了首相，那你就有麻烦了，伙计。所以让我们直奔主题吧，因为当我预告你要来参加播客时，我正在读你的书，我引用了书中的内容，这让我感觉到，显然，你一直以来所经历的，
ever since it came out, essentially, which is that you've become the focus for the kind of the rival perspectives on this, that you've become lauded by, say you've got quotes from James O'Brien on the front, for instance, but you've also had, I mean, you've had a firestorm of abuse and often incredibly racist abuse over this, haven't you? Yeah, actually, it's on both sides. I've got to say, some right-wingers have also liked it. Chris Patton, Andrew Marr.
自从书出版以来，本质上就是你已经成为了对此持不同观点的人的焦点，你受到了比如詹姆斯·奥布莱恩（James O'Brien）等人的赞誉，书封上就有他的引语，但你也遭受了，我的意思是，你遭受了铺天盖地的谩骂，而且往往是极其种族主义的谩骂，不是吗？是的，实际上，两边都有。我必须说，一些右翼人士也喜欢它。克里斯·彭定康（Chris Patten）、安德鲁·马尔（Andrew Marr）。
Yeah, it's been a shit show, basically. Can I say a shit show on the podcast? Yeah, absolutely. They'll put a little E, and that means that anyone under 15 won't listen to it. Well, people will just assume with the E that Tom's talking about general mutilation again. I'm sure we'll get on to that at some point. Well, a lot of left-wingers, the socialist worker reviewed it last week and said it wasn't angry enough.
是的，基本上就是一场灾难。我能在播客里说“烂摊子”（shit show）吗？当然可以。他们会加一个“E”标签，这意味着15岁以下的人不会听。好吧，人们只会因为那个“E”标签而认为汤姆又在谈论一般性的残害了。我相信我们迟早会谈到那个话题。好吧，很多左翼人士，比如《社会主义工人报》上周评论了它，说它还不够愤怒。
And so I get quite a lot from left-wing, and I've had a lot of abuse people saying, if I hate Britain so much, why don't I get back to where I came from, i.e. Wolverhampton? And loads of racist abuse, which I didn't really consider significant because it's par for the course nowadays if you're a journalist. But then The Guardian wrote a story, and they interviewed William Dalrymple, who's been writing similar stuff to me for many more decades.
所以我从左翼那里也得到了不少批评，我遭受了很多谩骂，人们说，如果我这么讨厌英国，为什么不滚回我来的地方，也就是伍尔弗汉普顿？还有大量的种族主义谩骂，我并没有觉得这有什么大不了的，因为如果你是一名记者，这在当今是家常便饭。但后来《卫报》写了一篇报道，他们采访了威廉·达尔林普尔（William Dalrymple），他写类似的东西已经几十年了。
And William said in his 20 or 30 years of being a historian of colonial India, he hadn't got one message of the kind I get, not one. And that made me realize it's about my colour. You know, when you're talking about empire, you're talking about race, you're talking about white people conquering brown people generally. And the thing is, until now, the imperial story has been told mainly by white men. And so suddenly when you get brown people like David Yoyosoga and me to a much more minor degree coming up and saying, oh, you know, empire wasn't quite like you think it was, it triggers a certain kind of person who can't see past your color and it becomes this
威廉说，在他作为殖民地印度历史学家的20或30年里，他从来没有收到过像我这样的一条信息，一条都没有。这让我意识到，这是因为我的肤色。你知道，当你谈论帝国时，你就是在谈论种族，你谈论的是白人征服棕色人种。问题在于，直到现在，帝国的故事主要是由白人男性讲述的。所以突然间，当你有了像大卫·奥卢索加（David Olusoga）和我这样——程度要轻得多——的棕色人种站出来说，哦，你知道，帝国并不完全是你想象的那样，这会触发某些人，他们无法超越你的肤色，这就会变成一场关于种族的有毒对话，而且无法逃避。
toxic conversation about race and there's no escaping it but the interesting thing about that though sanam um is that i mean your book absolutely isn't a diatribe is it i mean tom and i were talking about this before the show about the you know show, you know, you take us into the historiographical debate. So, you know, was it acquired in an absence of mind or wasn't it? Did it contribute to Britain's economy or was it even a drain on Britain's economy? And often you end up saying that there isn't an easy answer to a lot of these things. And in fact, at the beginning, I'm really struck that right at the beginning the beginning i mean that right at the outset you say you don't believe in doing moral audits of empires and it's obviously incredibly simplistic to say i mean we talked about this in
但有趣的是，萨特南，你的书绝对不是一篇抨击文章，对吧？汤姆和我在节目开始前谈过这个，你知道，你把我们带入了史学辩论。所以，它是“心不在焉”地获得的，还是不是？它对英国经济有贡献吗？还是说它甚至是英国经济的负担？通常你最终会说，很多事情并没有简单的答案。事实上，在开头，我真的很惊讶，就在开头，我的意思是，就在一开始，你说你不相信对帝国进行道德审计，说所有好或所有坏，或者任何这类事情，谈论任何巨大的、无定形的历史现象，显然是非常简单的。
our episode about global empires it's very simplistic to talk about any huge amorphous historical phenomenon say all good all bad or any of those kinds of things so did you so so you sort of it's no wonder i guess that you think you think that the abuse is directed at you personally rather than at the book basically yeah it's really great to hear that from you guys because you guys are mega brains and that flashman quote is the only way to approach empire because it was bloody complex we're talking about 500 years of history lots of things happened across the quarter of the planet. The idea that you're going to give it a five-star review, like a podcast, you know what I mean? It's insane,
我们在关于全球帝国的节目中谈到过这一点，谈论任何巨大的、无定形的历史现象，说它全好或全坏，或者任何这类事情，都是非常简单的。所以你，所以你大概，难怪我觉得你认为谩骂是针对你个人的，而不是针对这本书的。是的，从你们口中听到这些真是太好了，因为你们是超级大脑，而弗莱什曼的那段引语是接近帝国的唯一方式，因为它极其复杂。我们谈论的是500年的历史，在地球的四分之一区域发生了许多事情。那种认为你会给它一个五星好评的想法，就像播客一样，你明白我的意思吗？这太疯狂了，
but that is the only way the British really see empire. I mean, Tom asked people to suggest questions for this podcast. I had a look at them just now. I'd say 75% of them were about whether British empire was good or bad. That is, I blame Niall Ferguson. You know, we've had this obsession in this country about talking about whether Empire is good or bad. And now it's been seized upon by conservative ministers. You know, we're not allowed to, you know, do down British history. And it's such a silly way of looking at complex history. I mean, what does that mean? When you say you're proud of imperial history, what does that mean? You're proud of slavery? You're proud of abolition?
但这确实是英国人看待帝国的唯一方式。我的意思是，汤姆让人们为这个播客提建议。我刚才看了一下。我想75%的人都在问大英帝国是好是坏。这是，我怪奈尔·弗格森（Niall Ferguson）。你知道，在这个国家，我们有一种痴迷，就是谈论帝国是好是坏。现在这被保守党部长们抓住了。你知道，我们不允许，你知道，贬低英国历史。这是一种看待复杂历史的愚蠢方式。我的意思是，那意味着什么？当你对自己为帝国历史感到自豪时，那意味着什么？你为奴隶制感到自豪？你为废奴感到自豪？
But I suppose it goes the other way, doesn't it? I mean, it's equally ludicrous to say that you feel crippled with a sense of guilt, or you feel ashamed. So I suppose it cuts both ways, right? Totally. And so Jeremy Corbyn was saying a few years ago, we need to teach the crimes of empire. I've got no time for that. Then Michael Gove was saying, we need to teach the glories of empire. I've got no time for that. The only way to teach this stuff is by nuance and not to make it a balance sheet thing. But it's really hard to get away from that. I bet you we'll end up talking about that. I end up talking about it sometimes too. I'm sure we will. But one way to frame it, which I was kind of reflecting on, is that the argument over whether we should celebrate or feel ashamed of empire, which is obviously incredibly current
但我认为这反过来也一样，不是吗？我的意思是，说你感到被负罪感压垮，或者感到羞耻，同样是荒谬的。所以我认为这双向都适用，对吧？完全正确。所以杰里米·科尔宾（Jeremy Corbyn）几年前说，我们需要教授帝国的罪行。我没时间理会那个。然后迈克尔·戈夫（Michael Gove）说，我们需要教授帝国的荣耀。我没时间理会那个。教授这些东西的唯一方法是通过细微差别，而不是把它变成一种资产负债表。但很难摆脱这一点。我敢打赌我们最终会谈到这一点。我有时也会谈到它。我相信我们会谈到的。但有一种构建它的方式，我一直在反思，那就是关于我们应该庆祝还是为帝国感到羞耻的争论，这显然在当下非常热门，
at the moment, it's nothing new. And in fact, it's a theme that has run throughout the entire span of British imperialism. And we got a question from Mistress Gilbert Esquire, who I think teaches at Colston School, but just got renamed in Bristol. So the beginnings of British, I guess, English imperialism. She says, I've just taught the Tempest to year eight. What was the Jacobean attitude to empire? It seems it's okay to mock and demean the indigenous peoples, Prospero with Caliban. So I would say about the Tempest that actually it's incredibly ambivalent that Prospero is a complex figure and our attitudes to him vary. There are times where we feel great sympathy, I think, for Caliban. Certainly feel sympathy for Ariel, these figures from the island that Prospero has essentially enslaved.
这并不是什么新鲜事。事实上，这是一个贯穿整个大英帝国主义时期的主题。我们收到了吉尔伯特夫人（Mistress Gilbert Esquire）的一个问题，我想她在科尔斯顿学校（Colston School）教书，但那所学校在布里斯托尔刚改了名。所以英国，我想是英格兰帝国主义的开端。她说，我刚给八年级教了《暴风雨》。雅各布时代的帝国态度是什么？似乎嘲笑和贬低土著人民是可以的，普洛斯彼罗对卡利班就是这样。所以关于《暴风雨》，我会说它实际上极其矛盾，普洛斯彼罗是一个复杂的人物，我们对他的态度各不相同。有些时候，我认为我们对卡利班感到极大的同情。当然对爱丽儿也感到同情，这些来自岛屿的人物，普洛斯彼罗基本上把他们奴役了。
That sense of ambivalence is there right from the beginning, isn't it? Yeah, I mean, it's as much of a British tradition to moan about British empire as it is to celebrate it. The figures throughout history who attacked empire, I mean, go from George Orwell to Robert Graves, Saki, Gladstone, who ironically, you know, had a lot of his family wealth from slavery. We forget, actually, Colston's a good example. who ironically, you know, had a lot of his family wealth from slavery. We forget, actually, Colston's a good example. The guy who put up that Colston statue struggled to raise the money because not many people wanted that statue. Clive, Robert Clive, wildly unpopular in his lifetime, dragged in front of Parliament. Samuel Johnson saying, you know, he slashed his throat
那种矛盾感从一开始就存在，不是吗？是的，我的意思是，抱怨大英帝国和庆祝它一样，都是一种英国传统。历史上那些攻击帝国的人物，我的意思是，从乔治·奥威尔到罗伯特·格雷夫斯、萨基、格莱斯顿，讽刺的是，你知道，他的家族财富很多来自奴隶制。我们忘记了，实际上，科尔斯顿是一个很好的例子。那个竖立科尔斯顿雕像的人很难筹到钱，因为没多少人想要那个雕像。克莱夫，罗伯特·克莱夫，生前极不受欢迎，被拖到议会面前。塞缪尔·约翰逊说，你知道，他割断了自己的喉咙，
because he was overwhelmed by his own crimes. But then, you know, 100 years later, his statue is being put up in Whitehall. And the Viceroy of India is saying, you know what, this is needlessly provocative. But then now you have people celebrating it. And so, yeah, it's complex, isn't it? And these narratives change. But that anti-imperial narrative is as British as anything else, I'd say. So interesting. There's an interesting tension though here, right? Because at the end of your... I mean, one of the things in your book is you say
因为他被自己的罪行压垮了。但后来，你知道，100年后，他的雕像被竖立在白厅。印度总督说，你知道吗，这纯属挑衅。但现在你又有了庆祝它的人。所以，是的，这很复杂，不是吗？这些叙事在变化。但我会说，那种反帝国叙事和任何其他东西一样，都是英国式的。太有趣了。不过这里有一个有趣的张力，对吧？因为在你的书的结尾……我的意思是，你书中的一点是你说，
we should try and get to a kind of national consensus about the history of the empire. But in a way, the lesson of your book, and indeed of all the history of Britain's engagement with empire, is that there never has been a consensus. And you could argue, I mean, one of the things about any national story is that there never will be. I mean, could argue, I mean, one of the things about any national story is that there
我们应该尝试就帝国历史达成一种民族共识。但在某种程度上，你的书，乃至整个英国与帝国交往的历史的教训是，从来没有达成过共识。你可以争辩说，我的意思是，关于任何民族故事的一点是，永远不会有共识。我的意思是，可以争辩说，我的意思是，关于任何民族故事的一点是，
never will be. I mean, by definition, the past, because it's political, is always going to be divisive. So do you think there's an element that, you know, that the idea of a sort of everybody joining hands and saying, hurrah, we've united around a sort of a consensual account of our imperial past. I mean, to me, at least, that seems unlikely, shall we say. Yeah, no, history is argument. And so there's always going to be argument. There needs to be argument.
永远不会有。我的意思是，根据定义，过去因为它是政治性的，所以总是会引起分歧。所以你认为有一种因素，你知道，那种每个人手拉手说，好啊，我们围绕着一种关于我们帝国过去的共识叙事团结起来的想法。我的意思是，至少对我来说，这似乎不太可能，我们可以这么说。是的，不，历史就是争论。所以总会有争论。需要有争论。
We need to learn how to argue about this stuff in a more civilised way. Having said that, there are facts. And so lately, in the last few weeks, we've had a certain person writing in a mainstream press questioning the Tasmanian genocide about whether it happened and why it happened. And you know what, in all the, I think I've read nine or 10 different accounts of that, even from people like John Morris, who are very nostalgic about empire, none of them deny it as a fact, but suddenly it's been questioned. And I think there are such things as facts. And I do think there's something, there is fake history now in the way there was fake news.
我们需要学习如何以一种更文明的方式来争论这些事情。话虽如此，事实是存在的。所以最近，在过去几周里，我们有某个人在主流媒体上撰文质疑塔斯马尼亚种族灭绝，质疑它是否发生过以及为什么发生。你知道吗，在所有，我想我读过9或10种不同的相关记述，即使是像约翰·莫里斯（John Morris）这样对帝国非常怀旧的人，他们中没有一个人否认这是一个事实，但突然间它被质疑了。我认为事实是存在的。而且我确实认为，现在存在着某种虚假历史，就像曾经存在虚假新闻一样。
And because we know so little, the public debate is very thin. So on the topic of, say, of the Tasmanians, essentially, I mean, a genocide that actually inspired, you know, it's name checked at the beginning of H.G. Wells' War of the Worlds, kind of one of the great anti-imperial novels, because essentially the War of the Worlds is a visitation on London of makes the exercise of British imperial power increasingly toxic in the second half of the 19th century, I think, is what you were talking about earlier, which is the transformation of race into something supposedly scientifically based. And I guess that every great imperial people have tended to assume that they're the best, because essentially, if you don't think you're best, you're not going to have the self-confidence to go out and conquer people. And I can think of the Greeks, the Romans, the Arabs, I mean, everybody, you know, in their imperial heyday, they say we're the best. What's peculiarly toxic about the British manifestation of that, it seems to me,
因为我们知之甚少，公众辩论非常薄弱。所以关于，比如说，塔斯马尼亚人的话题，本质上，我的意思是，一场实际上激发了，你知道，它在H.G.威尔斯的《世界大战》开头被点名，这算是伟大的反帝国小说之一，因为本质上《世界大战》是对伦敦的一次造访，使得大英帝国权力的行使在19世纪下半叶变得越来越有毒，我想这就是你刚才谈到的，也就是种族向某种所谓的科学基础的转变。我想每一个伟大的帝国民族往往都倾向于认为自己是最好的，因为本质上，如果你不认为自己是最好的，你就不会有自信去走出去征服别人。我可以想到希腊人、罗马人、阿拉伯人，我的意思是，每个人，你知道，在他们帝国的鼎盛时期，他们都说我们是最好的。在我看来，英国这种表现形式中特别有毒的是，
is that a kind of cod Darwinism provides supposedly a scientific rationale for it. And even though that, I mean, basically, you know, the whole basis of that gets incinerated by the Nazis and it becomes a taboo subject. But your sense, and speaking as someone who is obviously kind of in the eye of this particular storm, your sense is that that has left an enduring legacy, even though it is not taught. Very, very few people would stand up and say, yes, I'm a scientific racist. But the legacy of that endures. Absolutely. Yeah. I would say it endures in our racial violence. I mean, when black people were being attacked in London in 1950s,
一种所谓的达尔文主义为它提供了所谓的科学依据。即使，我的意思是，基本上，你知道，这一切的基础被纳粹焚毁了，它变成了一个禁忌话题。但你的感觉，作为一个显然处于这场特定风暴中心的人，你的感觉是，尽管它没有被教授，但这留下了一种持久的遗产。非常非常少的人会站出来说，是的，我是科学种族主义者。但它的遗产依然存在。绝对是。是的。我会说它存在于我们的种族暴力中。我的意思是，当黑人在1950年代的伦敦受到攻击时，
the British Empire was still doing terrible things with the Mau Mau at the same time in Kenya. And the attitudes were the same towards black people in London as they were in imperial Kenya. And you see it, I would say, in the colour bar that ran through, you know, late empire and through British society in the 60s and 70s and 80s. I mean, working men's clubs in Wolverhampton had a colour bar until 1984, you know. Even now, I'd say there's certain pubs you go to if you're white or brown in Wolverhampton and certain pubs you don't go to. And I think there's a very powerful legacy.
大英帝国同时在肯尼亚对茅茅（Mau Mau）做着可怕的事情。伦敦黑人所受到的态度与帝国统治下的肯尼亚是一样的。你会看到它，我会说，在贯穿，你知道，晚期帝国和60、70、80年代英国社会的肤色歧视中。我的意思是，伍尔弗汉普顿的工人俱乐部直到1984年还有肤色歧视，你知道。即使现在，我想如果你是白人或棕色人种，在伍尔弗汉普顿有些酒吧你会去，有些酒吧你不会去。我认为这是一种非常强大的遗产。
The reason we have institutional racism in this country is that we had the institution of empire, which was in the 19th century racist, but I'm proud of it. But we've got to remember that race as a concept didn't exist between the 13th and 16th centuries. It's quite a modern idea, right? And also you've got this bizarre, as these scientific theories emerged in the 19th and 16th centuries. It's quite a modern idea, right? And also you've got this bizarre,
我们这个国家之所以存在制度性种族主义，是因为我们拥有帝国制度，它在19世纪是种族主义的，但我为此感到自豪。但我们必须记住，种族作为一个概念在13到16世纪之间并不存在。这是一个相当现代的想法，对吧？而且你还有这种奇怪的，随着这些科学理论在19世纪和16世纪出现。这是一个相当现代的想法，对吧？而且你还有这种奇怪的，
as these scientific theories emerged in the 19th century, you have this bizarre Aaron theory. Do you know about this? That encompassed Indians and Sikhs. It's part of the reason why we Sikhs were regarded as, you know, a martial race and kind of almost good brownies. But it's quite a lot to get my head around that. And, you know, Hitler is still quite popular in India, partly because of this air and race theory.
随着这些科学理论在19世纪出现，你有了这种奇怪的雅利安理论。你知道这个吗？它涵盖了印度人和锡克教徒。这就是为什么我们锡克教徒被视为，你知道，尚武种族，几乎是“好棕色人种”的部分原因。但我很难理解这一点。而且，你知道，希特勒在印度仍然很受欢迎，部分原因就是这个雅利安种族理论。
So, I mean, on that, but that's also the other side, I guess, of, say, the British engagement with specifically India, is that the discovery of Indo-European languages is kind of bred of a fascination on the part of many of the British officials who are in India with the civilization around them. So if there's a sense of cultural superiority and increasingly racial superiority, bewilderingly, it's interfused with a sense of fascination and kind of almost inferiority, because these officials who are studying Sanskrit are blown away by its beauties, by its power. They're saying that the masterpieces of Sanskrit literature are greater than those of Greek and Latin. So that is part of what makes it so difficult, isn't it? To get a handle on the empire,
所以，我的意思是，关于这一点，但这也是，我想，英国与印度交往的另一面，那就是印欧语系的发现，在某种程度上滋生了许多在印度的英国官员对他们周围文明的迷恋。所以，如果有一种文化优越感，而且越来越有种族优越感，令人困惑的是，它与一种迷恋感和几乎是自卑感交织在一起，因为这些研究梵文的官员被它的美、它的力量所震撼。他们说梵文文学的杰作比希腊和拉丁文学的杰作更伟大。所以这就是让它变得如此困难的部分原因，不是吗？要掌握帝国，
that the same people who are perfectly capable of shocking racism are equally capable of saying, you know, we were painted savages in the woods while the people in India were creating these great masterpieces. No, absolutely. And the same thing happened with the attitude towards the racial mixing in like interracial relationships
同样的人既能表现出令人震惊的种族主义，也同样能说，你知道，我们在森林里被描绘成野蛮人，而印度的人民却在创造这些伟大的杰作。不，绝对是。同样的事情也发生在对种族混合的态度上，比如跨种族关系，
they were more or less encouraged during a certain phase of the East India Company history you know I think the East India Company would pay for weddings between British people and India Indian wise but then the Victorians come along and it becomes possible for you know white women to travel to India and suddenly it's a taboo You'll lose your job if you have a mixed race relationship. And that's the same empire just over a few decades. Salim, I wanted to ask you about, you mentioned being a Sikh, and I thought that was one of the most interesting parts of your book. You talk about the experience of writing as a Sikh.
在东印度公司历史的某个阶段，它们或多或少受到鼓励，你知道，我想东印度公司会为英国人和印度妻子之间的婚礼买单，但后来维多利亚时代的人来了，白人女性去印度旅行成为可能，突然间这成了一个禁忌。如果你有跨种族关系，你就会丢掉工作。那还是同一个帝国，只是过了几十年。萨特南，我想问你，你提到你是锡克教徒，我觉得这是你书中我最感兴趣的部分之一。你谈到了作为锡克教徒写作的经历。
I mean, people sort of use the word Indian very vaguely, but the experience of specifically being a Sikh, and as you said, of Sikhs being seen as martial and as, inverted commas, good Indians. And you're quite interesting about how much that was constructed, that kind of, because some historians think this is an identity that's completely constructed and sort of foisted onto Sikhs by the British.
我的意思是，人们有点模糊地使用“印度人”这个词，但作为锡克教徒的特定经历，正如你所说，锡克教徒被视为尚武的，以及，加引号的，“好印度人”。你谈到这种身份在多大程度上是被构建出来的，这很有趣，因为一些历史学家认为这是一种完全被构建出来的身份，是英国人强加给锡克教徒的。
But you seem to think that that's not quite the whole story. Is that right? It's not quite the whole story because there was, we had our own martial theory, you know, history. The 10th Guru turned the Sikhs into a martial kind of creed. They had to because they're being persecuted and created an identity. But we were fading in numbers, you know, around the time of the
但你似乎认为这并不是全部事实。是这样吗？这并不是全部事实，因为我们有我们自己的尚武理论，你知道，历史。第十代古鲁（Guru）把锡克教徒变成了一种尚武的信仰。他们必须这样做，因为他们受到迫害，并创造了一种身份。但我们的数量在减少，你知道，在……左右的时候。
Indian mutiny. You know, the Sikhs were at risk of being merged into the Hindu mass, you know, and it was the British when we took the side, when the Sikhs took the side of the British during the mutiny, decided that we were trustworthy and therefore fetishized us, even published books explaining why we had exactly the right physique for being fighters, as I'm sure you can tell from me. We had the right size noses, the right shoulders. And it blew my mind that not only the way we see ourselves, the Sikhs, was created by British, was not created, but accelerated by British Empire.
印度兵变。你知道，锡克教徒面临着被融入印度教大众的风险，你知道，是英国人，当我们站在英国人一边时，当锡克教徒在兵变期间站在英国人一边时，决定我们是值得信赖的，因此将我们“拜物教化”了，甚至出版书籍解释为什么我们拥有作为战士的完美体格，我相信你可以从我身上看出来。我们有合适的鼻子大小，合适的肩膀。这让我大吃一惊，不仅是我们看待自己的方式，锡克教徒，是被英国人创造的，不是创造的，而是被大英帝国加速的。
But arguably, they saved us as a community because it became so popular to become you know a Sikh martial race employee of the British empire that the numbers increased massively in the decades afterwards and even Hindus joining the Indian army were encouraged to do the Sikh kind of religious ceremonies in order to sort of prove their martial valor yeah so can I jump in and ask you a quick follow-up to that? I'm fascinated. You talk a lot in the book, and you've got a very funny line that I think I've quoted in one of my own books, actually,
但可以说，他们拯救了我们这个群体，因为成为，你知道，大英帝国的锡克教尚武种族雇员变得如此流行，以至于在随后的几十年里人数大幅增加，甚至连加入印度军队的印度教徒也被鼓励进行锡克教的宗教仪式，以证明他们的尚武勇气。是的，我可以插话问你一个简短的后续问题吗？我很着迷。你在书中谈了很多，而且你有一句非常有趣的台词，我想我实际上在我的书里引用过，
about taxi drivers asking you where you're from, and you say, I'm from Wolverhampton. And, you know, people saying, go back home, and you say, well, I'm actually from Wolverhampton. Do you want me to jump on a train from Houston or whatever? When you were talking about the Sikhs in India, you used the word we to mean the Sikhs, and they was the British.
关于出租车司机问你从哪里来，你说，我来自伍尔弗汉普顿。而且，你知道，人们说，滚回家去，你说，嗯，我实际上来自伍尔弗汉普顿。你想让我从尤斯顿（Euston）或者其他什么地方跳上一列火车吗？当你谈论印度的锡克教徒时，你用“我们”来指代锡克教徒，用“他们”来指代英国人。
So did you find yourself kind of, when you're writing the book, and when you're thinking about these kinds of issues, do you find yourself consciously or unconsciously slipping between kind of subjectivities, if you know what I mean? To be honest, it's entirely unconscious. Loads of people have commented on the fact that I keep saying we when I talk about being British about the British
所以你在写书时，以及当你思考这些问题时，你是否发现自己会有意识或无意识地在各种主体性之间切换，如果你明白我的意思的话？老实说，这完全是无意识的。很多人评论说，当我谈论作为英国人，谈论大英帝国时，我一直说“我们”，我说是“我们”。显然，一位历史学家，我寄出——因为我不是历史学家，我在出版前把书寄给了五位不同的历史学家——他们都说你不能说“我们”，这是你作为本科生被告知的第一条规则，别再说“我们”了，那不是你。但我想要说“我们”，因为这就是我的感受。我希望它是一种包容性的东西，而不是指责性的，因为这种对话中太多是关于取消人们和妖魔化另一方。而且，你知道，作为锡克教徒，我没有那种感觉。我觉得自己和你们俩一样，都卷入了帝国。因为我认为有一种奇怪的，也许并不奇怪，
Empire I say we and apparently an historian I sent because I'm not a historian I sent the book out to five different historians before publication and they all said you can't say we it's the number one rule thing you get told as an undergraduate stop saying saying we, it's not you. But I wanted to say we, because that's the way I feel. And I wanted it to be an inclusive thing and not accusatory, because so much of this conversation is about cancelling people and demonising the other side. And, you know, as a Sikh, I don't feel that way. I feel as implicated in empire as probably you and Tom. Because I reckon that there is a kind of strange, maybe it's not strange,
但我的意思是，英国人与19世纪锡克教徒的关系中有一种非常明显的矛盾。因为英国官员和将军们在征服锡克帝国的问题上似乎有一种某种程度的负罪感。所以纳皮尔（Napier），他领导了这场战役，我的意思是，他说这是一场“无赖的生意”。而且，我想是埃尔芬斯通（Elphinstone），他是孟买总督，他说，因为这就在阿富汗战争之后，阿富汗战争的灾难，这提供了第一部弗莱什曼小说的题材，完全的灾难。然后英国人
but I mean a really telling ambivalence in the relationship of the British to the Sikhs in the 19th century. Because there seems to be a kind of certain measure of guilt on the part of British officials and generals over the conquest of the Sikh Empire. So Napier, who leads the campaign, I mean, he says it's a rascally business. And there's, I think it's Elphinstone, who is governor of Bombay, says that, because this is just after the Afghan war, the disaster of the Afghan war, which provides the theme of the first Flashman novel, complete disaster. And then the British
进去征服了信德（Sindh）。他有点说，这就像一个被揍了一顿的街头恶霸，进去揍了他的妻子。这些是你可能期望从今天丘吉尔学院（Churchill College）的“觉醒”学者那里听到的那种情绪，但却出自那些真正做了这件事的英国官员之口。而且一旦他们征服了它，他们就在模仿锡克教徒的许多帝国方法。所以使用开伯尔山口（Kaiba Pass）作为某种门户的想法，我的意思是，是锡克教徒开始了这一点。我想这几乎都归结于这样一个事实，
go in and conquer Sindh. And he kind of says that it's like a street bully who's been beaten up, who goes in and beats up his wife. And those are the kind of sentiments that you might expect to hear it from a woke academic at Churchill College today, but coming from the very British officials who did it. And then once they've conquered it, they're modeling a lot of their imperial approaches on that of the Sikhs. So the idea of using the Kaiba Pass as a kind of gateway, I mean, it was the Sikhs who began that. I think it's nearly all go back to the fact
锡克教徒差点打败了英国人。是的，完全正确。这绝对是在平衡之中。所以，同样，你看得越多，它就显得越复杂。是的，我应该说，事实上，必要时，英国人确实大量屠杀了锡克教徒，有时非常残忍，绑在大炮的末端。
that the Sikhs almost beat the British. Yes, completely. It was absolutely in the balance. And so, again, the more you look at it, the more complicated it comes to seem. Yeah, and I should say, actually, when necessary, the British did murder the Sikhs in large numbers and brutally sometimes tied to the ends of cannon.
你知道，有一个特定的锡克教派被炸得粉碎。那种被绑在大炮末端的惩罚的意义在于，你不能举行传统的葬礼，你知道，因为你的身体部位散落在很大的区域。所以基本上，很复杂。你在书中谈到，你在书中谈到，显然，我的意思是，这对被大炮炸飞的人有毁灭性的影响。但同样非常引人注目的是，
You know, there's a particular Sikh sect who were blown to smithereens. And the point of that punishment of being tied to the end of a cannon is that you can't have conventional funeral rites, you know, because your body's parts are scattered across a large area. So complex, basically. And you talk in the book, you talk in your book about the, obviously, I mean, this has devastating effect on the person who gets blown out of a cannon. But also rather strikingly,
你谈到了它可能对那些真正开炮的人产生的影响。完全正确。因为很难将你是一个好基督徒或带来文明的信念与做这件事的影响相协调。是的，观众中，人群中有时有妇女和儿童，你知道，看着人们被炸得粉碎。我的意思是，这在心理上一定是令人不安的。是保罗·吉尔罗伊（Paul Gilroy）谈到了这一点，关于殖民对殖民者的影响。
you talk about the effect it may have had on the people who actually fired them. Totally. Because it's very hard to square a conviction that you're maybe a good Christian or bringing civilization with the impact of doing that. Yeah, and there were women and children in the audience, in the crowd sometimes, you know, watching people being blown to smithereens. I mean, that's got to be psychologically disturbing. It's Paul Gilroy who talks about that, about the effect of colonization upon colonizers.
事实上，乔治·奥威尔，当然，在那篇关于他不得不射杀一头大象的伟大文章中。它叫《射杀大象》，对吧？以及他如何被迫感到荒谬，作为一个帝国主义者，你在帝国中的恐惧总是你会被嘲笑。但我会对此有一点点异议。我认为总有人会感到内疚，这在所有帝国中可能都是如此。人们，他们特定的性格，
And actually George Orwell, of course, in that great essay about where he has to shoot an elephant. It's called Shooting an Elephant, isn't it? And how he is made to feel ridiculous, that as an imperialist, your fear in empire is constantly that you're going to be laughed at. But actually, I would quibble with that a tiny bit. I think there's always people who do feel guilty, and that's probably been the case in all empires. People who are, their particular disposition,
也许是他们气质或智力上的倾向，他们会被羞耻或遗憾或任何东西所困扰。但实际上在某些方面，我的意思是，我得出了一个不同的结论，那就是我认为很多人并没有受到创伤，他们实际上喜欢经营帝国和征服别人。而且实际上，在某种程度上，这是一个更令人不安的故事，实际上很多人——我的意思是，我记得一个伟大的故事。我的意思是，这是一个完全不同的帝国。
maybe their temperamental or intellectual disposition is they will be haunted by shame or by regret or whatever. But actually in some ways, I mean, I take a different conclusion, which is I think a lot of people weren't traumatized and they actually loved running empires and conquering people. And actually in a way, it's a more disturbing story that actually lots of people, I mean, and they actually loved running empires and conquering people. And actually, in a way, it's a more disturbing story that actually lots of people – I mean, I can remember a great story. I mean, this is a completely different empire.
有一个故事——马丁·戴维森（Martin Davidson），他为BBC工作，负责他们的历史节目，讲述了一个关于他亲戚的故事。我不记得是不是了。他们当时在谈论匈牙利，那个亲戚说，哦，匈牙利，很棒的国家，很棒的景色。你知道，女人很漂亮，城市很英俊。他当时就问，你什么时候在匈牙利？那个人说，哦，我一生中最美好的日子。
There's a story – Martin Davidson, who worked for the BBC running their history programs, tells a story about a relative of his. I can't remember if it was. They were talking about Hungary, and the relative said, Oh, Hungary, wonderful country, great scenes. You know, the women are very pretty, very handsome cities. And he was like, when were you in Hungary? And this guy said, oh, best days of my life.
你知道，我是在1942年左右在那里的。你会想，天哪，这本应是一个你被困扰的非常黑暗的篇章。而你却把它记作这种快乐的，你知道，间隔年的等价物。我认为这几乎更令人不安，不是吗？很多人可能参与了帝国暴行，或者征服别人，或者把妇女和儿童炸得粉碎等等，但实际上也许他们并没有因此受到创伤。是的。事实上，我正在读亚历克斯·伦顿（Alex Renton）的书，那是关于他面对他家族的奴隶制历史。他讲述了一个苏格兰人去加勒比海的故事，第一天，他看到他的另一个苏格兰同事因为
You know, I was there in 1942 or something. And you think, geez, this is meant to be a very dark chapter that you're haunted by. And you're remembering it as this sort of jolly, you know, the equivalent of a gap year. And I think that's almost more disturbing, isn't it? That lots of people may have been involved in imperial atrocities or in conquering people or blasting women and children to smithereens or whatever, but actually maybe they're not traumatized by it. Yeah. Actually, I was reading Alex Renton's book, which is about him facing up to his family's history of slavery. And he tells a story about a Scottish guy who goes off to the Caribbean and on his first day, he sees another Scottish colleague of his punch a slave in the face for
上菜不对而打了一个奴隶的脸。他完全充满了沮丧。但10年后，这一切都不再困扰他了。你引用了，是什么，托马斯·西斯尔伍德（Thomas Thistlewood），是吗？牙买加的奴隶主，我的意思是，施加了无法形容的惩罚。并把这一切记录在日记里。把这一切记录在他的日记里。强奸、折磨。我的意思是，令人作呕，以至于我……是的，我甚至有一节课。
serving the food wrong. And he's absolutely full of dismay. But then 10 years later, none of it bothers him. And you quote, what's it, Thomas Thistlewood, is it? The slave owner in Jamaica who, I mean, inflicts unspeakable punishments. And records it all in a diary. Records it all in his diary. Rapes, torture. I mean, so revolting that I... Yeah, I even have a class.
不想被谈论。没有延伸到那个极端。事实上，我遇到他是因为他是第一个，已知第一个在西印度群岛打板球比赛的人。哦，哇。他用奴隶来开辟板球场的想法。是的，不，他把自己看作是一个启蒙运动的人，不是吗？他读了所有这些书，没意识到他在打板球。
Doesn't want to be talked about. Doesn't stretch to that extreme. And actually, the reason that I came across him is that he's the first person to, known person to have played a cricket match in the West Indies. Oh, wow. The idea that he's using slaves to carve out a cricket pitch. Yeah, no, he saw himself as a man of the Enlightenment, didn't he? He was reading all these books, didn't realise he was playing cricket.
板球从一开始就被玷污了，我想这就是这个教训，也许把那个讨论留到以后，留到以后，但我猜，我的意思是，我猜，再次，那个伟大的故事是，嗯，康拉德的《黑暗之心》，然后被翻译成《现代启示录》。殖民者可以进入一个黑暗之心，在那里所有的道德规范都被瓦解了。这是一种非常，我的意思是，那是一场显然源于帝国运作直接经验的噩梦。它挑战了，我想，我们对废奴主义的叙事，即我们卷入了一些可怕的事情，然后我们逐渐看到了光明。
Cricket has been tainted from the beginning beginning i think that's the lesson of this and maybe save that discussion for later for later but i guess i mean i guess that again though the the the great story of that uh is um conrad's um heart of darkness which then gets translated into apocalypseocalypse Now. The idea that the colonizer can enter a heart of darkness where all moral norms get dissolved. And that's a kind of very, I mean, that's a nightmare that is clearly bred of direct experience of the functioning of empire. And it challenges the, I guess, the narrative we have with abolition that we got involved in something terrible and we gradually saw the light.
事情并不总是那样发展的。好吧，我认为这是休息的完美时机。也许我们可以进一步探讨废奴主义是如何运作的。不，我要那样做，因为事实上我不想那样做，因为我想把奴隶制留到另一集。多米尼克，加入进来。我疯了。
It's not always the way it went. Well, I think that's the perfect point on which to have a break. And maybe we could pursue that theme a bit further on how abolition worked. No, I'm going to do that because actually I don't want to do that because I want to save slavery for another episode. Dominic, kick in. I've lost my mind.
好吧。汤姆一直试图带我们进入休息时间，但他完全失败了。所以我们要休息一下，广告后回来。一会儿见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。
Okay. Tom has been attempting to take us into the break, but he's completely failed. So we're going to have a break and we shall be back after the ads. See you in a minute. Goodbye. I'm Marina Hyde.
我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们一起主持《娱乐余温》（The Rest Is Entertainment），这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节，我们拉开帷幕，
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain
关于娱乐，我们告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目和抢先获得现场门票，请前往
on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to
therestisentertainment.com，网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史余温》。汤姆·霍兰德本打算带我们回来，但他已经放弃了。他说他喝得太多了。所以汤姆总是喝醉了做这些播客，但我没想到这会是个问题，
therestisentertainment.com that's therestisentertainment.com Welcome back to The Rest Is History. Tom Holland was going to bring us back in, but he's given up the ghost. He's been drinking too much, he tells us. So Tom has always done these podcasts drunk, but I didn't think it would be a problem,
therestisentertainment.com，网址是therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史余温》。汤姆·霍兰德本应带我们进入正题，但他已经放弃了。他告诉我们他喝得太多了。所以汤姆一直都是醉醺醺地录这些播客，但我没想到这会是个问题。
and now it is. Anyway, let's continue. Tom, I believe if you can get your words out, you have a question for Satnam. Thank you very much, Dominic. I do. And this is from Hazim Amin. And he asks, the British Empire shaped the modern world in the same way that the Arab empires or Chinese empires shaped their respective worlds. Wouldn't it be too simplistic to label this phenomenon, holy, good or bad? I think we I mean, I think we touched on that. But this is the interesting question.
现在就是了。总之，我们继续吧。汤姆，如果你能把话说出来的话，我相信你有一个问题要问萨特南。非常感谢，多米尼克。我确实有。这个问题来自哈齐姆·阿明。他问，大英帝国塑造现代世界的方式，正如阿拉伯帝国或中华帝国塑造它们各自的世界一样。将这种现象简单地贴上“完全好”或“完全坏”的标签，是否太简单化了？我想我们——我的意思是，我想我们已经谈到了这一点。但这确实是一个有趣的问题。
Aren't these labels themselves influenced by the empire? So in a sense, isn't our understanding of what is good and bad in the context of imperialism itself a legacy of imperialism? Yes, I guess you guys touched upon this in your podcast about empires in general, which I learned a lot from. And it's definitely useful to remember the British Empire wasn't the only empire that ever happened, right?
这些标签本身难道不是受到帝国的影响吗？所以从某种意义上说，我们在帝国主义背景下对什么是好、什么是坏的理解，难道不是帝国主义本身的一种遗产吗？是的，我想你们在关于帝国的播客中已经谈到了这一点，我从中获益良多。记住大英帝国并不是历史上唯一的帝国，这绝对是有益的，对吧？
And there was a survey done recently by Ipso Mori, which found that, you know, it surveyed people across Europe and found that actually people in the Netherlands were even more nostalgic than us. We were the second most nostalgic, but the Dutch, very nostalgic. And actually the Germans and the French too. And actually, the Germans and the French, too.
益普索莫里（Ipsos MORI）最近做了一项调查，发现——你知道，它调查了欧洲各地的人们，发现实际上荷兰人比我们更怀旧。我们是第二怀旧的，但荷兰人非常怀旧。实际上德国人和法国人也是如此。实际上，德国人和法国人也是如此。
And actually, I think you won't meet many Sikhs who say that Sikh empire was anything other than brilliant and cosmopolitan and peaceful. I was going to ask you that. Is that the, I mean, is that the, so what is the Sikh take on their empire, that it was brilliant? It was great. It was absolutely lovely, inclusive. We celebrated Christmas, even even for the British. And I've never heard a negative word said about the Sikh Empire. And it's important for me to remember that there's something in human nature that wants us to believe the best about it.
而且实际上，我认为你不会遇到多少锡克教徒会说锡克帝国除了辉煌、世界主义与和平之外还有什么别的。我正要问你这个问题。那是——我的意思是，那是——那么锡克教徒对他们帝国的看法是什么，它很辉煌吗？它很棒。它绝对可爱、包容。我们甚至为英国人庆祝圣诞节。我从来没听过关于锡克帝国的负面评价。对我来说，记住人性中有一种想要相信它最好一面的东西是很重要的。
What do Muslims and Hindus say about the Sikh Empire? Actually, I've never read it. All I've read is Sikh accounts of the Sikh Empire. I'd love to read a muslim or kind of interesting question of it yeah um there's another question that i think is fascinating and it comes at the end of your but it comes throughout your book and it's uh john andrews sort of picks up on it and he says given how awful things appear here and elsewhere i would be interested to know if satan remains as optimistic as he seems in the book that wider education about the facts of empire is enough to move this debate forward now i think this is a fascinating issue
穆斯林和印度教徒对锡克帝国有什么评价？实际上，我从来没读过。我读到的都是锡克教徒对锡克帝国的描述。我很想读读穆斯林或者——这是一个有趣的问题，是的。嗯，还有一个我认为很迷人的问题，它出现在你书的结尾，但它贯穿了你的整本书。约翰·安德鲁斯（John Andrews）提到了这一点，他说，鉴于这里和其他地方发生的事情看起来如此糟糕，我很想知道萨特南是否仍然像他在书中表现的那样乐观，认为关于帝国事实的更广泛教育足以推动这场辩论向前发展。现在，我认为这是一个引人入胜的问题。
in your book because you basically call for a lot of education about empire and and and the the sort of subtext or the assumption is the more people know about history the nicer they will be now i would i think we've done we've touched on this a few times, and I have what some people regard as an utterly deranged and heretical position, which is often the more people know about history and the more they think about it, the more likely they are to launch a preemptive strike on their neighbours.
在你的书中，因为你基本上呼吁对帝国进行大量的教育，而且——而且——某种潜台词或假设是，人们对历史了解得越多，他们就会越友善。现在，我想——我想我们已经谈过几次了，我有一种被某些人认为是完全疯狂和异端的立场，那就是通常人们对历史了解得越多，思考得越多，他们就越有可能对邻国发动先发制人的打击。
So do you genuinely think that learning, that A, there is a history that can unify, you know, 70 million people or whatever. And B, that there is a way to teach it that will genuinely bring people more together. I do. I mean, it has been quite hard to retain my optimism in the last six months,
所以你真的认为学习，A，有一段可以统一7000万人或无论多少人的历史。B，有一种教学方式能真正让人们更加团结。我是这么认为的。我的意思是，在过去六个月里，要保持我的乐观情绪确实很难，
given it's become a culture war. I mean, the arguments about empire between the government and Black Lives Matter supporters are toxic. And it's been weaponized war. I mean, the arguments about empire between the government and Black Lives Matter supporters are toxic. And it's been weaponized by the Tories in a kind of focus group way. So they've obviously done some research as they found out that saying
鉴于它已经变成了一场文化战争。我的意思是，政府和“黑人的命也是命”（Black Lives Matter）支持者之间关于帝国的争论是有毒的。而且它已经被武器化了。我的意思是，政府和“黑人的命也是命”支持者之间关于帝国的争论是有毒的。而且它已经被保守党以一种焦点小组的方式武器化了。所以他们显然做了一些研究，发现说
that being proud of imperial history works well in the Midlands and with the people who voted for them in the last general election. The reason I'm still optimistic is that young people know a lot more than I did. And they're really keen. They're getting their information and education from the internet,
为帝国历史感到自豪在米德兰兹地区以及在上次大选中投票给他们的人中很受欢迎。我仍然乐观的原因是，年轻人比我了解得多得多。而且他们真的很热衷。他们从互联网上获取信息和教育，
from Instagram, from films like Black Panther. And I feel like the business world has also actually embraced Black Lives Matter and history to a degree. So even though there's a massive backlash, I think in the end, young people will win. But Black Panther's a total fantasy, isn't it? It is, yeah. But there's a scene in the British Museum. Do you remember that bit?
从Instagram，从《黑豹》这样的电影中。我觉得商业世界实际上也在一定程度上拥抱了“黑人的命也是命”和历史。所以尽管有巨大的反弹，但我认为最终年轻人会赢。但《黑豹》完全是幻想，不是吗？是的，确实。但英国博物馆里有一个场景。你还记得那一段吗？
I haven't seen it, I'm afraid. I haven't seen it. I've never seen a superhero film because I boycotted it because of Spider-Man. Oh, you should watch it. I think it's the ninth biggest film of all time. I find them so boring. I always fall asleep.
恐怕我没看过。我没看过。我从来没看过超级英雄电影，因为我因为《蜘蛛侠》抵制了它。哦，你应该看看。我认为它是史上票房第九高的电影。我觉得它们太无聊了。我总是睡着。
I mean, I know this is basically the words of an old man, but I actually, I never thought I would say this, but there is too much action in the plot. No, Black Panther's definitely worth watching, and it left me feeling quite optimistic. And I just know from my nieces in my life who are
我的意思是，我知道这基本上是一个老人的话，但我实际上——我从没想过我会这么说，但情节里的动作太多了。不，《黑豹》绝对值得一看，它让我感到相当乐观。而且我从我生活中的侄女们那里知道，她们
in their twenties, they just really care, and they really get a lot of their stuff the classroom doesn't really matter that much i think but what is it that they're going to study that's bearing in mind that we've got 500 years of history and it spans the world and it's all incredibly complicated and we can't basically agree on anything a lot of kids do 40 minutes of history a week yeah the only statutory thing on the education in the history curriculum is the holocaust i think there's a bit of teaching of empire in key stage three, but it varies massively.
二十多岁，她们真的很关心，而且她们确实从课堂之外获取了很多东西，课堂其实没那么重要。但我认为，考虑到我们有500年的历史，它跨越了全球，而且一切都极其复杂，我们基本上无法在任何事情上达成一致，很多孩子每周只上40分钟历史课。是的，历史课程中唯一的法定内容是犹太人大屠杀。我想在关键阶段三（Key Stage 3）有一些关于帝国的教学，但差异很大。
But, you know, interesting, the Stephen Lawrence inquiry and the Windrush inquiry both made the same conclusion, that we need to teach British empire better. And I think we go around in circles. We have a racial crisis and we're like, oh, my God, we should reflect on the reason why we are a multicultural society and teach history better. And I believe we do. And I think parts of Britain are already doing that. The Welsh national curriculum has changed already. And hopefully England will catch up.
但是，你知道，有趣的是，斯蒂芬·劳伦斯（Stephen Lawrence）调查和疾风世代（Windrush）调查都得出了相同的结论，即我们需要更好地教授大英帝国。我认为我们是在兜圈子。我们面临种族危机，然后我们就像，哦，天哪，我们应该反思为什么我们是一个多元文化社会，并更好地教授历史。我相信我们做到了。而且我认为英国的部分地区已经在这样做了。威尔士的国家课程已经改变了。希望英格兰能迎头赶上。
I mean, it's a difficult one, isn't it? Because I always used to think that actually, again, another demented view of mine, I used to think that the Americans were very, I mean, there's an immigrant society I always used to marvel at the way in which they'd integrated Italian-Americans, Jewish-Americans, so on and so forth into their national story. But of course, what's very obvious now is that national story has always had holes. Some would say a colossal gaping, single gaping hole, and that their debate about history is even more, I mean, embittered to the sort of nth degree compared with ours.
我的意思是，这是一个难题，不是吗？因为我过去常认为——实际上，又是我的另一种痴呆观点——我过去常认为美国人非常——我的意思是，作为一个移民社会，我总是惊叹于他们将意大利裔美国人、犹太裔美国人等等融入他们国家叙事的方式。但当然，现在非常明显的是，那种国家叙事一直都有漏洞。有些人会说是一个巨大的、单一的巨大漏洞，而且他们关于历史的辩论甚至比我们的更——我的意思是，痛苦到了第N级。
And I don't know whether there's a European model. I don't know whether, I don't know enough about the French education system or the Dutch or whatever, about whether anybody has ever actually cracked this, of creating a model of an education system that basically most people are broadly happy with and a sort of national, a single... I mean, maybe that's the thing, that you can't have a single narrative that pleases everybody by definition.
我不知道是否有一个欧洲模式。我不知道，我对法国教育系统或荷兰或其他国家的了解不够，不知道是否有人真正破解了这个难题，即创造一个大多数人基本满意的教育系统模式和一种国家性的、单一的……我的意思是，也许这就是问题所在，即你不可能定义出一种让每个人都满意的单一叙事。
But the Germans have with World War II, but not necessarily with their own very problematic colonialism, you know. But I think German history was... The Nazis were so monstrous, and we've talked about this several times already on the podcast, that Hitler has come to serve the West basically Shakespeare is the greatest writer. Clearly, they think that partly because he's English and we speak English. So we're more sensitive to it. But also because clearly the fact that English is the global language and we exported this idea and therefore Shakespeare has a global resonance, it makes it an easier conceit for us to uphold. But I guess that kind of holding on to things like that is something that makes lots of people quite happy, not least those who are responsible for the tourist industry. There is a sense in which, is it not human nature to big up your own civilization, your own country, your own heritage. And perhaps one of the
但德国人在二战问题上做到了，但不一定是在他们自己非常麻烦的殖民主义问题上，你知道。但我认为德国历史是……纳粹太可怕了，我们已经在播客中多次谈到这一点，希特勒基本上已经成为西方……莎士比亚是伟大的作家。显然，他们认为这部分是因为他是英国人，我们说英语。所以我们对它更敏感。但也因为显然英语是全球语言这一事实，我们输出了这个想法，因此莎士比亚具有全球共鸣，这使它成为我们更容易坚持的自负。但我猜这种坚持某些东西是让很多人感到非常快乐的事情，尤其是那些负责旅游业的人。在某种意义上，难道夸大自己的文明、自己的国家、自己的遗产不是人性吗？也许其中一个
things that's actually striking about Britain, which again, all were pointed out, is that Britain perhaps is exceptional not for its jingoism, but for the sense of embarrassment that lots of people feel about its history. Yeah, I think that's all. The embarrassment has definitely been a prominent tradition. But I feel like the exceptionalism has accelerated in recent years. I mean, you've seen it with the coronavirus epidemic, this obsession with being world-beating. I actually listed the number of times politicians have said something was world-beating in the last year,
关于英国真正引人注目的事情，正如所有人指出的那样，是英国的例外论也许不在于它的沙文主义，而在于许多人对它的历史感到的尴尬。是的，我想就是这样。尴尬绝对是一个突出的传统。但我觉得这种例外论近年来加速了。我的意思是，你在冠状病毒疫情中看到了这一点，这种对“世界领先”的痴迷。我实际上列出了去年政客们说某事是“世界领先”的次数，
and it was something like 56 times. You know, the vaccines, our test and trace system which wasn't world beating um our science we have the best science in the world i think every country bigs themselves up but we take it to an extreme degree and actually our particular politicians boris johnson at the moment does it all the time you know he was doing it before he became a politician really you. This obsession with being number one. I don't think it serves any useful purpose, because as we've learned from Dominic Cummings, the government is not behaving in a
大约有56次。你知道，疫苗，我们的检测和追踪系统并不领先世界，嗯，我们的科学，我认为我们拥有世界上最好的科学。我想每个国家都会夸大自己，但我们把它发挥到了极致。实际上我们特定的政客，鲍里斯·约翰逊目前一直在这样做，你知道，他在成为政客之前就真的在做了。这种对成为第一的痴迷。我不认为它有任何有用的目的，因为正如我们从多米尼克·卡明斯（Dominic Cummings）那里了解到的，政府目前的表现并不
particularly world-beating way at the moment. But as Tom suggests, isn't that just... I mean, for example, you mentioned the coronavirus. Sweden, which had a sort of short-lived empire in the Baltic, and its empire was destroyed at Pultava in the early 18th century, and then became this sort of social democratic poster child.
特别领先世界。但正如汤姆所暗示的，那不只是……我的意思是，例如，你提到了冠状病毒。瑞典，它在波罗的海有一个短命的帝国，它的帝国在18世纪初的波尔塔瓦战役中被摧毁，然后成为了某种社会民主主义的样板。
Sweden also has a strong sense of exceptionalism, also has a belief that it led the world, and has had, at the very least, shall we say, a controversial experience during the pandemic. So I don't know that that's necessarily uniquely British, is it? I don't think it's uniquely British, but I think we do it more than anyone else. The Indians do as well at the moment. And actually, these culture wars we're talking about are occurring with Donald Trump's attempt to have a patriotic education. Modi's doing a load of stuff at the moment with Indian historians and trying to push a certain Hindu far-right view of history.
瑞典也有强烈的例外论感，也相信它引领了世界，并且在疫情期间有着——我们姑且说——至少是有争议的经历。所以我不知道那是否一定是英国独有的，是吗？我不认为它是英国独有的，但我认为我们比任何人都做得多。印度人目前也是如此。实际上，我们正在谈论的这些文化战争正随着唐纳德·特朗普试图进行爱国教育而发生。莫迪目前正在与印度历史学家一起做大量工作，试图推动某种印度教极右翼的历史观。
It's happening in Hungary and in Poland. Yeah. So we're not unique. But I guess on what basis would we say what Modi is doing in India is wrong? I mean, why shouldn't he push a hindu nationalist this is i've noticed this kind of post-modern tendency in your podcast to just uh say you know nothing nothing matters well it's but but it's just that in a way i can't believe we've had somebody on tom who's now analyzing our podcast and uh attacking us for being post-modernist yeah that's very postmodernist yeah but but because in a sense it seems to me
这在匈牙利和波兰也在发生。是的。所以我们并不独特。但我猜我们以什么为基础说莫迪在印度所做的是错误的？我的意思是，他为什么不应该推动印度教民族主义……这是——我注意到你们播客中有一种后现代倾向，就是说，你知道，什么都不重要。好吧，但这只是——但只是在某种程度上，我不敢相信我们请到了汤姆，他现在正在分析我们的播客，并攻击我们是后现代主义者。是的，那非常后现代主义。是的，但——但因为在某种意义上，在我看来
that that actually modi is whether consciously or not far more dramatically repudiating the legacy of british imperialism than say neru did um or the you know or the or the the the generations of the indian elites followed independence, which basically took for granted an essentially kind of British paradigm of there being the secular and that there's being distinct from things called religions. And that Modi, in a sense, is really trying to erase that. His sense of what Hindutva might have been may well be kind of erroneous and mythical, but it is a reaction against a view of the world that basically was spread by British and European and American imperialism more generally. And it does seem to me that as Western power retreats, so in countries like India,
实际上，莫迪无论是否有意，都在比尼赫鲁（Nehru）——或者说独立后跟随的几代印度精英——更剧烈地否定英国帝国主义的遗产，他们基本上认为英国式的世俗主义范式是理所当然的，即存在着与所谓的宗教不同的东西。而莫迪在某种意义上真的试图抹去这一点。他关于印度教性（Hindutva）可能是什么的感觉可能确实是错误的和神话般的，但它是对一种基本上由英国、欧洲和美国帝国主义更广泛传播的世界观的反应。而且在我看来，随着西方力量的撤退，在像印度、
in China, in the Middle East, in the Muslim countries, a lot of things that were exported culturally and ideologically by European empires are going to come under question. Yeah. I mean, Modi's relationship to the British Empire is very interesting because his political tradition doesn't have a particularly good story to tell. You know, they weren't part of the fight against British Empire in particular. So, I mean, Will Dranipal
中国、中东、穆斯林国家，许多由欧洲帝国在文化和意识形态上输出的东西都将受到质疑。是的。我的意思是，莫迪与大英帝国的关系非常有趣，因为他的政治传统并没有什么特别好的故事可讲。你知道，他们并不是反抗大英帝国斗争的一部分。所以，我的意思是，威尔·德拉尼帕尔（Will Dranipal）
finds himself attacked quite often for his writing about the East India Company in India. But yeah, it's happening all around the world. I haven't answered your question, have I? No, no. I think not answering the question is... Well, I like the fact that it's an open conversation, actually. Because I mean, I think isn't this what's part of the trouble with when people have these arguments about the British Empire, about empires generally,
经常因为他关于印度东印度公司的写作而受到攻击。但是的，这在世界各地都在发生。我还没回答你的问题，对吧？不，不。我认为不回答问题是……好吧，我实际上喜欢这是一个开放对话的事实。因为我的意思是，我认为当人们对大英帝国、对帝国进行这些争论时，这难道不是麻烦的一部分吗？
that they expect that you can come to a definitive, simple, and often morally charged answer. And I mean, one of the great things about your book it seems to me is that you actually are so open um and i wonder whether that's partly because you've come to it in a way you you have come to it as both a Sikh and and a Briton but also it's quite i'm quite interested in that you seem to have come to it with so little baggage if that makes sense i think the key thing is i've come to it as a non-historian yeah that's what you guys but i don't really read history books i've read dominion and uh maybe two other books but i don't read three books you you only read three books in your life you've read three books and one of them had to be tom's
他们期望你能得出一个明确的、简单的、通常带有道德色彩的答案。我的意思是，你的书的伟大之处之一在我看来是，你实际上是如此开放。嗯，我想知道这是否部分是因为你以某种方式来到这里——你既是锡克教徒又是英国人，但我也很感兴趣的是，你似乎带着如此少的包袱来到这里，如果这说得通的话。我认为关键在于我作为一个非历史学家来到这里。是的，这就是你们——但我真的不读历史书，我读过《多米尼恩》（Dominion），嗯，也许还有另外两本书，但我没读过三本书。你一生只读过三本书，其中一本还是汤姆的。
have you read dominic's books i have a no. No, no. I've seen his TV programs. You've seen the TV programs. Thank you. I've seen the TV programs. I'll take that. Jesus. But I mean, actually, that's a very important point because I guess everyone listening to the podcast is probably someone who reads history books. Lots of people don't.
你读过多米尼克的书吗？我没有。不，不。我看过他的电视节目。你看过电视节目。谢谢。我看过电视节目。我接受这个。天哪。但我的意思是，实际上，这是一个非常重要的观点，因为我猜听播客的每个人可能都是读历史书的人。很多人不读。
I read novels. I probably write novels. I want character, sexual intrigue, plot. There's a lot of that in this podcast. A lot of sexual intrigue. Sexual tension a lot of that in this podcast a lot of sexual intrigue sexual tension that's something else um and history doesn't give you that and also history books assume you know a lot i mean i really struggled reading books on british empire because there's basic things i didn't know also they ought way too long every history book is too oh god don't
我读小说。我可能写小说。我想要人物、性阴谋、情节。这个播客里有很多。很多性阴谋。性张力，这个播客里有很多，很多性阴谋，性张力，那是另一回事。嗯，历史给不了你这些。而且历史书假设你知道很多。我的意思是，我读关于大英帝国的书真的很挣扎，因为有些基本的东西我不知道。而且它们太长了，每一本历史书都太——哦，天哪，别
go there don't say this why are they so so long? There's a lot to say. You've got to put in a chapter about the new romantics, haven't you? So my ambition was to write a short book on British history. That was really part of my mission because there's not anything. I think you're so right
去那里，别这么说。为什么它们那么长？有很多话要说。你得写一章关于新浪漫主义的内容，不是吗？所以我的抱负是写一本关于英国历史的短书。这确实是我的使命的一部分，因为没有这样的书。我想你是对的，
that, of course, what most people's sense of history does not come from school, does not come from reading books. It's a kind of inchoate, vague sense. And perhaps that's why the debate over the British Empire is so toxic, because it's either slavery, racism, people blown out of cannons, or it's, I mean, the joke is railways, isn't it? And, um, both helmets, uh,
当然，大多数人对历史的感觉不是来自学校，不是来自读书。这是一种模糊的、不明确的感觉。也许这就是为什么关于大英帝国的辩论如此有毒，因为它要么是奴隶制、种族主义、人们被大炮轰死，要么是——我的意思是，笑话是铁路，不是吗？还有，嗯，头盔，嗯，
democracy and, um, whatever. Uh, and essentially they, they can exist in people's minds, completely untethered to any facts whatsoever, really.
民主，嗯，等等。嗯，本质上它们——它们可以存在于人们的脑海中，完全与任何事实脱节，真的。
Also, the less, you know, I'm saying the opposite of Dominic here. I think the less, you know, about British imperial history, the stronger your opinions.
而且，了解得越少——我在这里说的是与多米尼克相反的话。我认为你对英国帝国历史了解得越少，你的观点就越强烈。
I actually think it's one of those cases where actually people, if they did know more, the only possible conclusion is that you've got to be nuanced. It's the only possible conclusion, right? I think that is very optimistic because I think often people who know, I mean, it's not always the way that people who know a lot about something tend to have very nuanced views. I mean, we're all familiar with the kind of conspiracy theorist who knows more about the Kennedy assassination than you could ever learn in a lifetime, and then has some incredibly abstruse and elaborate theory about how it was done by aliens or something. So you're more optimistic than I am. And you're also more optimistic because you talk a lot about imperial
我实际上认为这是一种情况，即如果人们确实了解更多，唯一的可能结论是你必须细致入微。这是唯一的可能结论，对吧？我认为这非常乐观，因为我认为通常了解的人——我的意思是，了解某事很多的人往往有非常细致的观点，这并不总是这样。我的意思是，我们都熟悉那种比你一生能学到的还要了解肯尼迪遇刺案的阴谋论者，然后他有一些关于它是如何被外星人或其他东西完成的极其深奥和复杂的理论。所以你比我更乐观。而且你更乐观，因为你谈论了很多人们的帝国
amnesia or historical amnesia in people. But I often think one of the weird things about history is those of us who are interested in history think everybody should be interested in history and should be thinking about it more than they are. But actually, a lot of people, I mean, this is kind of real heresy to the listeners of this podcast, but a lot of people just don't give a damn about history, do they? No, I think history is something you get into as you get older. And I worry about it because I think the moment you're interested more in the past than the future you're old it's over yeah I'm so old yeah I mean by that definition I've been old since I was about four well I was so into dinosaurs I mean I completely I was yeah
健忘症或历史健忘症。但我经常认为历史奇怪的事情之一是，我们这些对历史感兴趣的人认为每个人都应该对历史感兴趣，并且应该比现在更多地思考它。但实际上，很多人——我的意思是，这对这个播客的听众来说是一种真正的异端——但很多人根本不在乎历史，不是吗？不，我认为历史是你随着年龄增长而进入的东西。我对此感到担心，因为我认为当你对过去比对未来更感兴趣的那一刻，你就老了，一切都结束了。是的，我太老了。是的，我的意思是，按照那个定义，我从四岁左右就老了。好吧，我太沉迷于恐龙了，我的意思是，我完全——我确实是，是的。
I've always been more interested in the past I guess but then satnam if you think that if you think it's bad to be interested so much in the past and not in the future, how come you think that we should devote so much attention to looking backwards in schools? Well, it's about how much you don't spend your entire life looking at the past. But to work out your path in the future, you need to know where you're coming from, man. How the hell? I mean, Brexit is a good example. We're trying to redefine our relationships with the world at the moment.
我一直对过去更感兴趣，我想。但萨特南，如果你认为对过去如此感兴趣而对未来不感兴趣是不好的，那你怎么认为我们应该在学校里投入这么多精力去回顾过去呢？好吧，这是关于你不要把整个人生都花在看过去上。但为了制定你未来的道路，你需要知道你来自哪里，伙计。怎么可能？我的意思是，英国脱欧就是一个很好的例子。我们目前正在试图重新定义我们与世界的关系。
And often we don't remember what we did to them during the empire. And I think they find that shocking. My favourite fact in all my research was in Tony Blair's memoir, when he was handing back Hong Kong to the Chinese, he says, oh, you know what, I was very only dimly aware of the history. It's like you can bet the Chinese bloody know about the history. You can bet every Chinese school kid is told about the Opium wars now you've been disobliging about tony blair you definitely have burned your boats with tom no not at all not at all because i would say i mean you know people say that boris johnson is the most imperial uh of recent prime ministers i would say tony
而且我们经常不记得我们在帝国期间对他们做了什么。我认为他们觉得这很令人震惊。我在所有研究中最喜欢的事实是托尼·布莱尔（Tony Blair）的回忆录，当他把香港交还给中国时，他说，哦，你知道吗，我对这段历史只有模糊的了解。就像你可以打赌中国人肯定知道这段历史。你可以打赌每个中国学生现在都被告知鸦片战争。你刚才对托尼·布莱尔不客气，你绝对已经和汤姆断绝了关系。不，一点也不，一点也不。因为我会说——我的意思是，你知道，人们说鲍里斯·约翰逊是最近几任首相中最具帝国色彩的，我会说托尼
blair was a long way i mean i think the iraq war was absolutely the exemplification of a kind of deep-rooted British imperial attitude that combines kind of the ruthless deployment of hard power with a kind of moralistic sense that we knew better. Absolutely, yeah. And that was basically the attitude that enabled us to conquer people and feel that it was for their good. But isn't one of these things, Tom, though, well, to both of you, I guess, that there's an assumption that when the reality, when the substance of imperial power has gone, when the colonies are independent and so on, the attitude should change overnight. And I'll often read that in books looking back at the 1950s and 1960s,
布莱尔差得远了。我的意思是，我认为伊拉克战争绝对是一种根深蒂固的英国帝国态度的例证，它结合了无情的硬实力部署和一种我们更了解的道德主义感。绝对是，是的。这基本上就是使我们能够征服人们并觉得这是为了他们好的态度。但汤姆，难道这不是其中之一吗？嗯，对你们俩来说，我想，有一种假设是，当帝国权力的现实、实质消失时，当殖民地独立时等等，态度应该在一夜之间改变。我经常在回顾20世纪50年代和60年代的书籍中读到这一点，
and they'll say Britain clung on to its ideals. But nations don't change, and a national imagination can't change. I mean, that's why actually when you're talking about race and racism, I mean, I was really struck by that reading the book because I thought, you know, I read a lot of books in sort of 70s, 80s, in the 70s, 80s West Midlands from the local library or something, that by today's standards would undoubtedly be considered, well, by any standards, would be considered racist. I mean, biggles or something, let's say.
他们会说英国坚持其理想。但国家不会改变，民族想象力也不会改变。我的意思是，这就是为什么实际上当你谈论种族和种族主义时——我的意思是，我读这本书时真的很受触动，因为我想，你知道，我在70年代、80年代的西米德兰兹郡从当地图书馆读了很多书，按照今天的标准，毫无疑问会被认为是——好吧，按照任何标准，都会被认为是种族主义的。我的意思是，比格尔斯（Biggles）之类的，我们说。
Enid Blyton. Well, I mean, Enid Blyton is a very good example, the three gollywogs. So unless you're going to have this sort of colossal purge immediately, which no country ever really does. I mean, we had Ian Kershaw talking about denazification the other week, and that denazification was, in his words, a farce. Countries aren't going to shed.
伊妮德·布莱顿（Enid Blyton）。好吧，我的意思是，伊妮德·布莱顿是一个很好的例子，那三个小黑人偶（gollywogs）。所以除非你要立即进行这种巨大的清洗，而没有任何国家真正这样做。我的意思是，我们上周请伊恩·克肖（Ian Kershaw）谈论去纳粹化，而那次去纳粹化，用他的话说，是一场闹剧。国家不会轻易摆脱。
It's almost unrealistic to imagine that a country is going to sort of shed its skin instantly. And the process of losing your imperial ideals probably is a question of centuries, do you think? Yeah, I mean, that for me was one of the most kind of destabilizing points of the book, was realizing that even though I supposedly had this brilliant education, you know, from a grammar school and at Cambridge University, I'd been colonized in the sense that, you know, I was in my final term at Cambridge before I read a single brown author. All my views of even India were through the Western eye, you know, and also learning about how the British, how they ultimately conquered a lot of Indian kingdoms was not in the battlefield, it was by sending the princes
想象一个国家会立即脱胎换骨几乎是不现实的。而失去帝国理想的过程可能需要几个世纪，你觉得呢？是的，我的意思是，对我来说，这是书中那种最令人不安的观点之一，意识到尽管我理应接受这种辉煌的教育，你知道，来自文法学校和剑桥大学，但我已经被殖民了，因为，你知道，我在剑桥的最后一个学期才读到一位棕色人种作者的作品。我对印度的一切看法都是通过西方的眼睛，你知道，而且还了解到英国人是如何最终征服许多印度王国的，不是在战场上，而是通过把王子们
through the English public school system. That's how you really won people, you turn them into English gents. And I know what you're saying. I think the psychological legacies of empire are fascinating, and I didn't really understand them until I read Paul Gilroy, Edward Said, you know. I wonder whether actually one of the reasons why we can't escape the legacy of British imperialism is because, in fact, imperialism was an expression of something much deeper, which was the rise of capitalism. And perhaps that's the reason why the Dutch and the English, who essentially invent capitalism, are the people who seem most kind of self-confident
送进英国公立学校系统。这就是你真正赢得人们的方式，你把他们变成英国绅士。我知道你在说什么。我认为帝国心理遗产很迷人，直到我读了保罗·吉尔罗伊（Paul Gilroy）、爱德华·萨义德（Edward Said）的作品，我才真正理解它们。我想知道，实际上我们无法逃避英国帝国主义遗产的原因之一是否是因为，事实上，帝国主义是更深层东西的表达，那就是资本主义的兴起。也许这就是为什么荷兰人和英国人，他们本质上发明了资本主义，是那些看起来最自信的人
in their imperial legacy. Because I think that particularly what happens in the i suppose the 19th century that explosive period of of growth is best summed up by marx in the in the in the opening pages of the um communist manifesto where he talks about the achievements of the bourgeoisie he talks about how they have utterly transformed the world in the space of a century. They have changed the patterns of everybody around the world. And basically, we still live in that world. The British Empire may be gone, but the capitalism that the British developed is still what makes the world go round. That to some extent is Neil Ferguson's argument, right? I mean, that's empire making the modern world. I was there, I was thinking I was being
在他们的帝国遗产中。因为我认为特别是在19世纪发生的事情，那个爆炸性的增长时期，马克思在《共产党宣言》的开篇几页中总结得最好，他谈到了资产阶级的成就，他谈到了他们如何在短短一个世纪内彻底改变了世界。他们改变了世界各地每个人的模式。基本上，我们仍然生活在那个世界里。大英帝国可能已经消失了，但英国人发展的资本主义仍然是让世界运转的东西。在某种程度上，那是尼尔·弗格森（Niall Ferguson）的论点，对吧？我的意思是，那是帝国塑造现代世界。我当时在那里，我以为我是一个
a Marxist. But it turns out I'm actually a narrow conservative. Quite the opposite. I find it fascinating that one of the reasons why the city of London is slightly disconnected from the British economy now is because it developed
马克思主义者。但事实证明我实际上是一个狭隘的保守派。恰恰相反。我觉得很有趣的是，伦敦金融城现在与英国经济略有脱节的原因之一是它发展了
for empire to serve this international network and not necessarily to serve Britain, you know, and that is something we still live with now. When it comes to, you know,
为了帝国，为了服务这个国际网络，而不一定是为了服务英国，你知道，这是我们现在仍然生活在一起的东西。当谈到，你知道，
the economics of empire, that was the part of the book that most made my brain want to fry because there's a consensus amongst economics, economists that actually empire didn't enrich Britain overall because it costs so much to run these colonies, to go to war, that overall it didn't enrich britain overall because it costs so much to run these colonies to go to war that overall it didn't enrich us and when you start facing up to that i don't know what that does to your theory tom but well i think i think it backs it because i was prompted to think that by reading but by reading your account of that that in a sense, what makes empires?
帝国的经济学，那是书中让我大脑最想炸裂的部分，因为经济学家之间有一种共识，即实际上帝国并没有让英国整体上变得富有，因为它维持这些殖民地的成本太高了，去打仗，所以总体上它并没有让英国整体上变得富有，因为它维持这些殖民地的成本太高了，去打仗，所以总体上它并没有让我们变得富有。当你开始面对这一点时，我不知道这对你的理论有什么影响，汤姆，但——好吧，我想我想它支持它，因为我被阅读——通过阅读你对那一点的描述所触动，即在某种意义上，是什么造就了帝国？
I mean, it's self-confidence, it's power, it's a sense of mission, but it's also the ability to persuade people that your way of life and your way of seeing the world is something that might be worth signing up to. And the British Empire featured all of those, but it featured it basically because it was an expression of, I guess, what we would now define as modernity. And the moment the British imperialism comes to seem old-fashioned, which it increasingly does, then basically it's doomed. And that's why the American variant of imperialism is so much more successful. And it's also why the Chinese variant of imperialism now is such a challenge to American imperialism, because it looks modern it looks sophisticated it's kind of stuff that people
我的意思是，它是自信，它是力量，它是使命感，但它也是说服人们你的生活方式和你观察世界的方式是值得加入的东西的能力。大英帝国具备了所有这些，但它具备这些基本上是因为它是——我猜，我们现在会定义为现代性的东西的表达。而当英国帝国主义开始显得过时的时候，它确实越来越显得过时，那么基本上它就注定了。这就是为什么美国式的帝国主义要成功得多。这也是为什么现在的中国式帝国主义对美国帝国主义构成了如此大的挑战，因为它看起来现代，看起来复杂，它是人们
might conceivably want to sign up to now that is a book Narfogson hasn't written and you should do that one come on Holland's literary career it's about to take a very unexpected turn and I think if I'm going to do that we'd better stop the podcast now I better go off and will you be capable of taking us out after your failure to take us into the break I can if I'm going to do that, we'd better stop the podcast now. I'd better go off and... Will you be capable of taking us out after your failure to take us into the break? I can't. My brain still feels fuddled by my over-thinking last night. I think it's quite fitting that we really... We've talked around a lot of issues, but we haven't really resolved them.
现在可能想加入的东西。那是一本尼尔·弗格森还没写的书，你应该写那一本。来吧，霍兰德的文学事业，它即将发生一个非常意想不到的转折。我想如果我要那样做，我们最好现在就停止播客。我最好走开，在你未能带我们进入休息时间后，你有能力带我们结束吗？我可以——如果我要那样做，我们最好现在就停止播客。我最好走开，并且……在你未能带我们进入休息时间后，你有能力带我们结束吗？我不能。我的大脑仍然因为昨晚的过度思考而感到混乱。我认为我们真的……我们谈论了很多问题，但我们并没有真正解决它们，这很合适。
But that's how it should be. Because I think one of the lessons of Satnam Sanghera's book, Empire Land, is that actually some of these issues are very difficult, if not impossible, to resolve. And actually the interesting and fruitful thing is the argument. And to have lots of podcasts on. Or the conversation, should we say, rather than the argument.
但这就是它应该有的样子。因为我认为萨特南·桑赫拉（Satnam Sanghera）的书《帝国之地》（Empire Land）的教训之一是，实际上其中一些问题是非常困难的，如果不是不可能解决的话。实际上，有趣且富有成效的是争论。并且要有很多播客。或者我们应该说对话，而不是争论。
I think actually that's one of the problems with the empire and the discussion of it, is that it tends to be an argument where it should actually be a conversation. One of the great things about Satnam's book, for those of you who haven't read it, is that there's lots of room to disagree with it to engage with it but it's it's it's written a very measured and nuanced way that is a pleasure to read and it's very funny often
我认为实际上这就是帝国及其讨论的问题之一，即它往往是一场争论，而它实际上应该是一场对话。对于那些还没读过萨特南书的人来说，这本书的伟大之处之一是，有很多空间可以不同意它，可以参与其中，但它写得非常适度且细致入微，读起来是一种乐趣，而且通常非常有趣。
and that's surprising in a book and he's from wolverhampton which is detailing a lot of not being mentioned enough and is a wolves fan like all great people are. Elgar, Sangira, Sandbrook, the Holy Trinity, as we're known in the West Midlands. And Tom, do you want to have anything to say on this or nothing? I've got absolutely nothing to add to that. Brilliant. Okay, Sadan, thank you so much for coming on the podcast. Thank you. It's been an honour.
这在书中令人惊讶。而且他来自伍尔弗汉普顿（Wolverhampton），这在书中被提及得不够多，而且他是一个狼队（Wolves）球迷，就像所有伟大的人一样。埃尔加（Elgar）、桑赫拉（Sanghera）、桑德布鲁克（Sandbrook），三位一体，正如我们在西米德兰兹郡所知。汤姆，你对此有什么想说的吗，还是什么都没有？我对此绝对没有什么可补充的。太棒了。好的，萨特南，非常感谢你来到播客。谢谢。这是一种荣幸。
And we'll see you all next time. Thank you. thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early access ad free listening There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们下次再见。谢谢。感谢收听《历史的其余部分》（The Rest Is History），获取额外剧集、抢先体验、无广告收听。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。